economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna está conmigo en el estudio
Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas noches
comenzamos en Perú en donde tal parece
la sensación que hay es que las
protestas comienzan a ceder poco a poco
con el paso de los días Bueno es que
esta crisis social y política ha dejado
ya bastantes estragos en el sector
agrícola en el sector minero Y por
supuesto en el turismo pero en las
últimas semanas el número de carretera
bloqueada se ha reducido en tres cuartas
partes desde el máximo que se alcanzó en
enero según la autoridad de carreteras
de Perú los bloqueos persisten y se
concentran mayoritariamente en una sola
región la región suroriental de puno el
emblemático Machu Picchu reabrió sus
puertas este mes a medida que caía la
intensidad de los disturbios una buena
noticia para las empresas peruanas y
para el Banco Central de ese país pese
al aumento en los precios Perú detuvo
este mes la serie de subidas de tipos de
interés ya que los responsables de la
política monetaria Están preocupados por
la perspectiva de crecimiento algunos
analistas
que el Banco Central será el primero de
toda la región en empezar a recortar los
tipos de interés en un escenario en el
que la economía sigue bastante débil
pero otros analistas también temen que
las protestas pueden reavivarse al no
existir una solución a esta problemática
ese país ha tenido siete presidentes
desde el año 2016 una reciente encuesta
de ipsos muestras como el 76% de los
peruanos quieren que Dina boluarte
dimita y el 70% desea que se convoquen a
nuevas elecciones este mismo año pasemos
ahora a analizar el costo de este primer
año de guerra o de invasión de Rusia a
Ucrania y el impacto de las sanciones
que ha impuesto occidente en las cuentas
de la federación de Rusia bueno la
guerra ya por cumplirse un año se acaba
las cuentas públicas de Rusia a un nivel
que no se había visto desde hace más de
un cuarto de siglo en enero el gasto
aumentó en el 59% mientras que los
ingresos Fiscales en Rusia cayeron en un
35% en comparación con el mismo periodo
del 2022 las cuentas Ya generan un
déficit presupuestario de unos 24 mil
millones de dólares que supone más de la
mitad de lo previsto para todo el 2023
el gobierno ruso atribuye el hueco
fiscal a factores externos puntuales
dicen y pronostica que el desequilibrio
se va a suavizar en los próximos meses
pese la cantidad de sanciones
occidentales la economía no da muestras
de un colapso y muestra incluso
resultados mucho mejores que los que
prohíben las autoridades de ese país
tras un año de Guerra El golpe el
producto interno bruto fue del dos coma
cinco por ciento según datos
preliminares del Ministerio de finanzas
y del Banco Central pero la economía
rusa comenzará a sentir el impacto
financiero más fuerte este año esto tras
el veto de los países del g7 la Unión
Europea y Australia a las importaciones
de petróleo Ruso y también a la
imposición de un precio tope de 60
dólares por barril para su venta por vía
marítima que entró en vigencia a partir
de diciembre ya veremos cómo le va a la
economía rusa a lo largo de este año
pasemos ahora a hablar de Walmart que
presentó sus perspectivas económicas
justamente para el 2023 cómo les va a ir
bueno el líder minorista pronóstico
ganancias por debajo de las estimaciones
y advirtió que el gasto de los
consumidores podría presionar los
márgenes de beneficio muchos factores
están presionando a la reserva Federal
de Estados Unidos a continuar elevando
los tipos de interés Esto hace que las
familias comiencen a cambiar sus hábitos
de compra optando por productos
necesarios y más baratos por esto
Walmart pronosticó ganancias entre
5,96,05 dólares por acción para el año
hasta enero del 2024 por debajo de las
estimaciones de los analistas que eran
de 6,50 dólares por acción pero no es el
único Home Depot también pronosticó
beneficios anuales inferiores a los
esperados ya que la subida de los
precios afectó a la demanda de productos
de mejora del hogar a continuación
hablamos de un tema que tal vez a
ustedes les va a interesar y es los
resultados del mayor ensayo mundial de
una semana laboral de cuatro días Qué
dijeron Bueno más de 60 empresas
británicas participaron en el
experimento de seis meses de duración
que permitió a casi 3000 empleados
trabajar Un día menos a la semana
manteniendo el mismo salario el estudio
revela que nueve de cada 10 empresas
mantendrá en la semana laboral reducida
o tienen previsto hacerlo el resultado
es contundente una semana laboral de
cuatro días es más productiva para la
mayoría del personal y las empresas que
la tradicional de cinco días según este
estudio la productividad no se vio
afectada por las semanas laborales
reducidas y los ingresos incluso
aumentar un 35% En comparación con
periodos similares de años anteriores
Los investigadores concluyeron también
que la salud y el bienestar de los
empleados había mejorado Pues a mí me
encanta mi trabajo pero un día más de
descanso no nos vendría nada mal Jorge
que tomen nota los jefes es todo en la
economía a continuación el debate
[Música]